mazda seen it all man he was there from
the jump he was there the the origin
story of kobe covington before colby was
kobe kobe was corning him they were
training partners roommates nobody knows
each other better so to me
you got to throw everything you you you
gotta throw everything out that you know
about these two because they know each
other so freaking well
it's such a tough fight to call
my
my heart thinks that moswell can pull
this off and get a k and get a finish
i don't know why couldn't tell you
the the odds would disagree with you i
think draftking says kobe a you know
minus 300 for a reason yeah minus 335.
horry models plus 260. not a terrible
bet to battle horry mosbidal
kobe ain't finishing jorge
but also the the one caveat of all this
is whori got flatlined the last time he
entered the octagon how does that affect
a veteran of jorge mosbidal he's been
around the game forever but he's never
been flatlined like that ever ever ever
so we don't know how that's going to
affect rory
has he lost confidence united can be as
wild which makes him special
does he know that anytime he pressured
forward on kobe kobe would take him down
so he doesn't want to spend the you know
the majority of the fight on his back so
there's these things where this is such
to me this is a gimme fight meaning it's
literally whoever you like more bet on
him those odds should to me do not i
don't care that colby's at minus 300.
take it out of this yeah take all that
out of this we don't know how what it's
going to look like the household going
to react after being flatlined how's
colby going to react knowing that
mazwell knows all his tricks and his
takedowns and his pressure and he knows
how to deal with it he knows what gets
to kobe he knows that you know the the
chinks in colby's armor who's going to
you know be able to mentally
deal with that stuff better that's who's
gonna win this fight so who put your
money on whoever you like better forget
about the odds for these experts quote
unquote there's no experts in the fight
game but these experts
they don't [ __ ] know what's going on
here it's whoever can
you know
imply their will and really you know get
the other guy to do what you know he's
not used to doing and i you know there's
a lot of experience with mazda all man
and he's very explosive i would be
willing to bet if this fight ends in a
finish it's gonna be hospital